Oi boa noite pessoal meu nome é Henrique
Ferreira eu sou formado incenso
tecnologia engenheira de informação como
estado em física e atualmente faço phd
na área de informática de materiais que
envolvem Inteligência Artificial e
física de materiais hoje hoje à noite eu
vim falar para vocês sobre o que eu
aprendi durante a Minha Vida
Universitária EA transformar em 5 lições
que eu gostaria de passar para vocês são
cinco lições eu acho que todo mundo
deveria saber antes de entrar numa
universidade A primeira é um clássico
prometi você já passaram por aquele
momento de prestar um vestibular e
ficarem um pouco angustiado se vocês não
passaram vocês vão passar em algum
momento Vocês ficam angustiados sem
saber que curte fazer se vocês estão de
humanas ou exatas se você deve levar em
consideração o mercado hoje
a fazer aquilo que vocês amam bem eu
acredito que na verdade o curso na
maioria dos casos é um menos importante
vocês não deveriam ficar angustiadas na
hora de escolher um curso entre um curso
e façam ele porque primeiro porque o
conhecimento quando você coloca
conhecimento nessas caixinhas é uma
forma bastante produtiva de você
realmente aprender um conhecimento real
por exemplo um raio que cai numa árvore
no meio da floresta né as pessoas podem
falar raio é coisa de físico a água da
chuva é coisa de químico a árvore no
meio da floresta é coisa de biólogo mas
na verdade o fenômeno do raio acertar a
árvore no meio da floresta é um fenômeno
único que envolve tudo isso né existe
essas caixinhas que a gente queria nessa
Fashion são coisas de um anos vitrúvio
foi o arquiteto que viveu no século 1
antes de Cristo para vitrúvio né ele
escreveu um livro sobre o que você devia
fazer para ser um bom arquiteto tem um
Victor Hugo escreveu né que para seu
Rock Até que você deveria saber sobre
arquitetura Claro
E você também tem querer saber sobre
engenharia sobre fisiologia sobre
política sobre história sobre filosofia
você venha saber muito mais do que só
aquilo da sua profissão para vitrúvio
quanto mais você soubesse melhor
arquiteto você seria para ele
conhecimento era um só você é uma vez
que você começar a se aprender algo você
está de aprendendo sobre tudo outras
pessoas famosas né que seguiu isso Por
Exemplo foi da 20 a gente foi o italiano
né viveu na Itália renascentista lá por
volta de 1500 e ele estudava fisiologia
estudava engenharia né e ele é
extremamente famoso até os dias de hoje
né ele tem essa visão de que o
conhecimento é muito mais amplo tu tem
que ser aprender você tem que aprender
sobre tudo provavelmente ele leu o livro
de vitrúvio nos dias de hoje a gente
chama isso de multidisciplinaridade E
interdisciplinaridade então mais do que
escolher um curso Procure um curso que
tem a interdisciplinaridade por quê
Porque isso é muito mais poderoso para
você conseguir aprender algo
e de maneira como o mundo real funciona
agora que se você quiser decidir pelo
mercado bem se você sabe o que o mercado
vai precisar daqui 10 15 anos daqui
cinco anos na verdade eu diria para você
não fazer um curso para você e abrir uma
empresa atualmente você vai ganhar muito
mais dinheiro porque você tem um poderá
indicar evidência de realmente saber o
que minha casa vai precisar para que
cinco dez anos a verdade que ninguém
sabe que tipo de profissional mercado
vai precisar para daqui 10 15 anos tá se
você pensar que um curso universitário
na mente levar 4 até 6 anos você tem que
ter uma uma margem de previsão muito
grande né E ninguém tem essa massa de
previsão ninguém sabe com certeza Qual é
o profissional que vai ser necessário no
futuro então se você pensar em escolher
o mercado pelo que está aquecido hoje
talvez você erre porque o que está
aquecido hoje não pode não não
necessariamente vai estar aquecido
amanhã aí então pensar pelo mercado às
vezes é muito arriscado agora você pode
decidir fazer aquilo que você ama isso
seria uma boa escolha o problema é que
quando você tem 17
e aproveite você não sabe o que você
realmente ama porque porque eu digo isso
porque você não viveu o suficiente você
não experimentou o suficiente você não
conhece as coisas o suficiente pois você
pode falar que adora que ama engenharia
mas nunca esteve numa obra você pode
dizer por exemplo que ama ser médico mas
você nunca viu um cadáver E aí você não
sabe se você realmente é uma aquilo
então não se cobre demais o melhor seria
você entrar numa universidade e depois
escolher seu curso porque você quiser
tempo de aprender sobre as diferentes
profissões é teria essa experiência
procure experiências isso é o mais
importante na hora de decidir não se
preocupe demais na hora de escolher um
curso a você vai ter que experimentar
você vai descobrir isso
e depois que você entra na universidade
né Acontece muito de você acaba culpando
seus professores por todos os problemas
que acontecem com você então a minha
segunda lição é não culpe os seus
professores a normalmente Você viveu na
lá no ensino fundamental ensino médio
vocês e a aula sentava e copiava o
professor tava escrevendo uma blusa aí
você fazia um procedimento de quase como
um monge copista você copiava o
conhecimento no máximo você decorava
conhecimento isso não é uma boa forma de
aprender e aí você entra na universidade
pensa que aprender é isso e você começa
a culpar seu professor porque você não
aprendeu direito e na verdade aprender
não é isso aprender muito mais do que
isso não é decorar não é copiar coisas
né aprender algo mais profundo e assim
lá o conhecimento Então você deve
aprender a aprender mais o que que eu
passo os professores tome as rédeas da
sua formação e aprenda a aprender a não
é fácil aprender aprender eu teria que
ter um outro Sedex para conseguir
explicar pelo
a experiência sobre isso de aprender
aprender mas eu posso dar algumas dicas
sempre que você tiver aprendendo sobre o
assunto ensine sempre que você ensina
você aprende mais então ensina alguém
que sabe menos o que você alguém que
sabe mais do que você você vai ver que
nesse processo vão surgir várias dúvidas
e você vai aprender mais vai sim lá
melhor aquele conteúdo tá e cruza
informações não adianta assistir aula do
professor a e achar que você não
entendeu a matéria astral do professor
ar do professor B do professor ser
quando você vai procurar no livro
didático óleo do livro de óleo no livro
A livro B no livro sempre e hoje pessoal
a gente não tem muita desculpa hoje com
todas as pessoas têm na palma da mão um
celular um computador que tenha acesso a
informações conhecimento quantidade de
conhecimento que nem o melhor erudito de
50 anos atrás tinha né aquele cara
querem se tô pede ambulante hoje ele não
sabe mais do que você tem acesso na
palma da sua mão com clique use essas
ferramentas tá aprenda a usar elas isso
é muito importante não culpe seu
professor aprenda a
é a minha terceira Edição é a seguinte
quando você entrar numa universidade
Aproveite a oportunidade de estar numa
universidade porque tem o nosso país é
um país muito desigual poucas pessoas
têm a chance de fazer em uma
universidade a verdade no mundo Poucas
pessoas tem uma chance de fazer a
universidade se você tivesse
oportunidade Aproveite de maneira mais
intensa possível porque a universidade é
um lugar legal para você aproveitar esse
de maneira intensa pensa um pouco a
universidade normalmente congrega as
mentes mais inteligentes de uma nação
então pessoas de diferentes lugares do
país né diferentes lugares do Brasil por
exemplo vão para uma universidade outro
estado com elas têm diferentes histórias
diferentes repertórios diferentes
conhecimentos elas enxergam as coisas de
maneira diferente então você quer
conversar com pessoas inteligentes que
pensam diferente de você tem uma
história diferente você é só um
excelente oportunidade né para você se
tornar mais inteligente conviver com
pessoas inteligentes de forma mais
inteligente então essa é uma
oportunidade importante mas não só isso
viver a universidade vai te proporcionar
a oportunidade que você não sabia se
você vai na universidade assistir aula e
volta para casa você perde uma série de
riquezas que a universidade tem para te
oferecer eu posso por exemplo dar o meu
exemplo lá para 2013 eu fiz uma
disciplina né de introdução ao
laboratório de física e eu mandei bem do
experimento profissional gostou de mim e
para ter gostado ela me convidou para
fazer uma iniciação científica Tu não
entende ação científica Essa professora
falou Henrique porque você não viu a
representante de sente vai ser o que é
exatamente isso vou procurar Olhei no
site da universidade Conversei com um
colega meu de laboratório e a gente se
candidatou para representação discente
nós somos eleitos né e a gente eu
conheci durante a representação discente
é outros representantes discentes gente
resolveu fazer uma chapa para um desse
épico diretório central de estudantes
concorremos e ganhamos como usar uma
sugestão do desse é a gente resolveu
fazer uma coisa que era uma os
solidários que é basicamente pegar
alunos que têm um conhecimento melhor
sobre determinada disciplina ele dá uma
aula gratuita para vários outros alunos
que estão com dificuldade e a gente
arrecada alimentos para
a questões de caridade né e não decisões
né eu mesmo fui dar um de fenômenos
térmicos e eu lembro que são experiência
muito bacana porque tinham 200 pessoas A
sala estava lotada a gente arrecadou um
centro 300 quilos de alimento e foi
muito legal a experiência de passar lá
umas duas horas passando meu
conhecimento e pegamos térmicos para
essas pessoas um belo dia estava
navegando nas redes sociais e uma pessoa
que eu não conhecia me mandou uma
mensagem quando eu queria participar de
uma equipe para uma competição
internacional de física Oi PT o
International Office se torna homem eu
sei que eu posso Bora ó eu não tenho uma
equipe com essa pessoa né Essa pessoa
chama Matheus Pessoa e a gente conhece
aqui para nós estamos representar o
Brasil na Suécia Suíça e Rússia e
inclusive na Rússia ela ficamos em
terceiro lugar nós somos uma das a
primeira equipe das Américas a
participar de uma final mas em 2018 foi
uma experiência incrível e um dia
pergunta por mata-juntas como é que você
chegou em mim como é que você
o encontro ele falou assim ah Sabe
aquele onde critério que vocês devam Ela
traz é alguns anos atrás então eu tava
lá assistindo eu tava fazendo falamos
térmicos e o assistir a sua aula e eu
gostei e aí eu fui atrás de você então
eu não sabia lá atrás que quando eu tava
fazendo essas tendências que eu ia
acabar chegando a defendeu o Brasil na
Rússia mas só aconteceu porque porque eu
aproveitei a oportunidade eu fui criando
essas autoridades na universidade chove
a oportunidade então entra numa
universidade e faça uma missão
científica faça monitoria participe da
representação discente do desse Existem
várias entidades estudantis vai fazer
carro de corrida vai fazer é participar
dos três é para mexer com eletrônica vai
empresa júnior existem muitas Eu também
para subir de volta aqui para lançar
foguetes e inclusive conhecia a pessoa
que me indicou para estar aqui hoje
nesse Sedex que é uma outra exemplo de
como você cria oportunidades durante sua
vida Universitário Então aproveite Viva
intensamente é uma oportunidade única
bem
a atenção é a seguinte normalmente você
entrar na universidade pensando no final
que quando você vem diploma eu acho que
você deveria não se preocupar tanto com
esse papel na verdade eu acho que você
deveria esquecer o seu diploma porque
pensamento o diploma né o pedaço de
papel não faz cirurgia vou pegar de
papel em um projeto a prédios vai dar de
papel não pilota Aviões Vou pegar os
papel no problema no computador sem
programa quem faz cirurgias quem projeta
prédios constroem aviões pilota aviões é
você então você tem que tomar essa
responsabilidade você seu diploma
esquece aquele pedaço de papel no final
você que ter responsabilidade aprender
você que vai assinar você que vai fazer
os cálculos você que vai fazer a
cirurgia na pessoa então você tem que
ter essa responsabilidade esqueça o
pedaço de papel no final você é o seu
diploma mas na quinta lição é não se
cobre demais porque porque a vida não é
determinística você não sabe realmente o
que
E aí existe muita contingência muitas
coisas aleatórias que acontecem na vida
você não sabe se você vai ter a mesma
oportunidade durante todos os seus anos
de estudo por exemplo então não se cobre
demais vi passa tudo com
responsabilidade mas não se cobre demais
nem sempre fazer a b e c te leva a dele
tá porque a vida é contingente não é
determinística mas se você tivesse a
visão de que o conhecimento é amplo
nessa visão de vitrúvio de da 21
conhecimento é amplo você sempre pode
aprender não eu não trabalho estudando
aquele tópico específico da sua
profissão sempre que você aprende sobre
o que disser para você aprende mais
sobre aquilo que você faz se você tem
essa visão que vai além de escolher um
curso se você tem essa autonomia de você
pegar as caixas do seu aprendizado e
você aprender a aprender se você tiver
essa visão de aproveitar as
oportunidades criar essas oportunidades
de viver elas intensamente e todas elas
com a responsabilidade de saber que você
é o responsável você vai ser o seu
diploma no final você vai ser você é o
responsável por aquilo que
é aquilo que você faz eu te garanto que
não importa o mercado como mercado vai
estar daqui cinco dez anos não importa
os problemas que vão acontecer na sua
vida você vai sair extremamente bem
preparado para encarar esses problemas
bem era isso que eu tinha pra dizer hoje
boa noite muito obrigado a
E aí